Hello Internet!
Welcome to Film Theory, the show that ate
the Devil Fruit giving us the power
to ruin your favorite childhood series.
So as the general audiences
start to cool on
superheroes, the bigwigs over at Hollywood
have been looking for their next big
treasure trove of IP they can plunder
and turn into billion dollar hits.
And one of the wells that they've
been turning to in recent years: anime.
And even though legendary classics like
Dragon Ball, Ghost in the Shell, and Cowboy
Bebop haven't turned out that great,
hasn't stopped them from trying some more.
Feels like every week
we hear about a beloved anime
getting its own live action adaptation.
YuYu Hakusho is getting one at Netflix.
Gundam is getting the big screen treatment
over at Netflix.
Netflix is trying their hand
at My Hero Academia. Sword Art
Online is making the jump over to Netflix.
Wow that is a lot of Netflix.
Hope it turns out better than Death Note.
Wait, they're doing another live action
Death Note at Netflix.
Okay, so that's a lot,
and given Netflix's previous track record,
I think it's fair to be a bit nervous.
But hey, who knows. Maybe they've figured out
a way to course correct the ship.
In fact, we won't have to wait
long to see if that's the case
because a few days after this theory airs,
they're going to be dropping their version
of a live action One Piece.
In case you don't know about this
massively popular anime,
One Piece is all about the swashbuckling
Monkey D. Luffy and his ragtag crew of straw
hat pirates all searching for the treasure
of the last king of the pirates.
As the king explained before he died.
Now, if you thought this was going
to be a quick adventure...
*Laughs*
Oh, you
sweet summer child you're so wrong.
One Piece is one of the world's longest-
running anime with over a hundred manga
volumes, 1000 episodes,
and a quarter century's worth of content
with no real signs that they're going
to be stopping anytime soon.
Got to be real here
with you, loyal theorist,
we've been wanting to cover One Piece
on the channel for a long time.
But there's just so much that you have
to watch and read to cover your bases.
Watching the anime
alone would take you over 17 days straight
with no sleep and no bathroom breaks.
Just from that alone,
I was really skeptical
when Netflix announced
that they were making the show.
But after seeing the trailer,
I've got some cautious optimism.
Here's hoping they stick the landing.
But with this Netflix adaptation
coming along and basically asking "what if..."
That got some cogs turning in my head.
Yeah, what if the One Piece were real?
And by that I mean,
what if the world of One Piece of a real?
This is a franchise
with an incredibly unique setup
in a world
that is instantly recognizable.
So what would happen
if we applied real world science to it?
That's right, friends,
we're doing a certified theorist
classic today.
If this thing were real,
it would be absolutely terrifying.
Because, make no mistake,
if the world of One Piece were real,
it would be dangerous, disastrous,
and it would ruin basically any attempt
to better your life.
Hoist your Jolly Rogers, loyal theorists,
we're setting sail.
So before we can really dive
into why you wouldn't
want to live in the world of One Piece,
we have to break down
just how different it is from our own.
Zooming out, you can immediately spot
some pretty big differences.
First of all, almost the entire planet
is covered in ocean with some small island
continents and archipelagos dotted here
and there. On the real planet Earth,
with all of our massive continents, about
70% of the planet's surface is water.
So for the world of One Piece,
we're talking closer to 90%.
The biggest landmass is undoubtedly
the Red Line, a very long, very
skinny continent of red rocky mountain
jutting out of the ocean,
which runs all along
what's basically the prime meridian
of the planet. Because of this, One
Piece's oceans are split
into five main bodies of water.
The four biggest
are the north, south, east and west
blues basically separated
into the four hemispheres of the planet.
But the fifth body of water is actually
the most important: the Grand Line,
a wide ocean stream that wraps around
the entire equator of the planet.
This stretch of ocean
is incredibly perilous
and often called
the most dangerous in the world.
Normal compasses don't work here. Currents
and weather are erratic and extreme,
and much of the wildlife is deadly.
There's a reason its earned itself
the nickname the Pirates Graveyard.
So other than that
forbidding label on the Grand Line,
what would the big issues of this planet
actually be?
Well, the first problem
the world of One Piece would face
actually comes
from its most iconic feature: the fact
that it's just covered in ocean water.
See, this one fact would probably mean
that the world's inhabitants
don't have time to fight over
who's going to get the One Piece first
because they're too busy fighting over
another, more essential resource, one
required to survive: water. Uh, fresh water.
I'm sure
I don't need to tell you, ocean water
not safe to drink.
All that
salt is not going to give you a good time.
In the real world,
fresh water only makes up about 2.5%
of the planet's total water supply.
And amongst that already
minuscule percentage,
most of that is trapped in the atmosphere,
in ice caps,
or is so deep under Earth's surface
that it won't see the light of day.
The only water that's truly available
for humans to consume
are those found in underground aquifers
or in freshwater lakes and rivers.
I mean, here's a crazy fact for you:
if all of Earth's water were shrunk down
to the size of your typical water bottle,
the amount that would be fresh
and available
would be about a quarter of a milliliter.
That is literally less than a drop
in a bucket.
Now, remember, all of these calculations
are in relation to Earth, a planet
that has 30% of its surface
covered in land, land
that has massive lakes and rivers.
And even we still have fresh water
shortages.
Now, take away
all the continents, the Great
Lakes, the rivers, the streams,
and replace it all
with even more giant oceans
full of undrinkable saltwater;
people are going to struggle.
Sure, some islands in One Piece
probably have fresh water.
Obviously,
real world islands like those in Hawaii
have plenty of fresh groundwater
reserves and local spring water.
But those can run dry.
And pumping wells near coastlines
puts you at a massive risk of accidentally
sucking up ocean water, contaminating
your pool. Factor in the limited farmland
available on the islands
and you've suddenly created a world
that's going to be forever in conflict,
not over a piece of pirate treasure,
but over a lack of food and water.
The second major environmental problem
you're going to run into in the world
of One
Piece is coming from its second
most striking physical feature,
the Red Line continent
that basically cuts the planet in half.
How so?
Well, this is basically going
to make a ton of the islands on the planet
borderline impossible to live on.
To explain what I mean,
let's just take a look at this map
of our very real world, specifically
the West Coast of the United States.
You ever notice how so much of the West
Coast is incredibly green?
Basically running from Canada
all the way to central California,
everything is covered in trees
and wildlife. It's beautiful.
And then there's almost a straight line
where everything to the east becomes
much more brown full of deserts
and dry grasslands.
Why has it happened?
Well, that straight line separating the
two regions is the Cascade Mountain Range.
See, there's basically a permanent breeze
flowing
into North America from the Pacific Ocean
until it reaches the Cascades
and is suddenly deflected up.
That rapid upward movement forces
the moisture carried by the wind
to condensate, making a bunch of rain
and creating an ecosystem
that's fit for a bunch of plant growth.
This is why cities in the Pacific
Northwest are so famously rainy
and why the forests there are so abundant.
But on the opposite side of the mountain
range, you have the opposite effect.
Since all the moisture was taken
out of the air by the mountains,
the ecosystems are much drier and hotter
on the other side. The phenomenon is
fittingly known as the rain shadow effect
since the mountains
are casting a metaphorical shadow
where there's no rain on the far
side of the range.
So now let's apply
what we just talked
about to the world of One Piece.
Since the Red Line is basically a giant
ring of incredibly tall mountains, it's
going to cast an equally enormous
rain shadow. Since the Grand Line
ocean current travels from west to east,
then we would expect the wind
to also be hitting that western side
of the Red Line mountain range,
making the eastern side of the Red Lines
devastatingly dry. And wouldn't you know it,
but that's exactly where our intrepid
straw hat heroes start their adventure.
The first six arcs of One Piece's story
take place in the East Blue Ocean
and eventually end up at the Red Line.
So this planet, we're even somewhat
realistic,
every single island
they visit at the beginning of the show
would be an arid desert wasteland
where there just isn't a lot of water
and rain for life to take hold.
And hey, it gets even worse from there
when you take into account the next aspect
of the world of One Piece: the Grand Line.
Or rather, what's around the Grand Line.
See, flanking above and below
the Grand Line is a stretch of sea
known as the Calm Belt. And while that
might sound like it's going to be smooth
sailing, it actually creates a giant problem.
The Calm Belts here aren't
just expanses of pleasant seas,
they're completely still
and I mean completely still.
In contrast to
all the crazy currents and unpredictable
winds of the Grand Line, the Calm Belts
have no wind to catch your sails,
no currents to carry you along.
And that right
there would be outright disastrous,
maybe even apocalyptic in a real life
climate system.
If water and wind just flat out stopped
like it hit a brick wall at the Calm Belt,
that means that the oceans in the northern
and southern hemispheres
aren't sharing any water.
Similarly, since the Red Line continent
is basically dividing the world in half,
it means that the oceans in the West
and eastern
hemispheres are also not sharing water
besides the pathetic trickle
that just gets through
at the reverse mountain.
Basically each ocean in the world of One
Piece is in its own
entirely enclosed system.
Why is that so bad? Temperature.
Because the planet's a big old spheroid,
the central part of the equator receives
a whole lot more of the sun's heat
compared to the poles.
That's one of the big reasons that places
like Central America, Central Africa,
and Southeast Asia have such warm,
tropical climates.
However, the currents
running throughout our oceans transport
the warmer waters from the equator down
towards the poles, thereby increasing
the overall temperature of those areas
and making them more temperate
and habitable for more creatures,
including us humans.
If you want a really good example
of how this works,
look no further than Europe.
You ever notice how far north Europe
actually is on the map?
Cities known for their warmer
climates like Rome actually sit
on the same latitude as more notoriously
cold climates
like Boston.
Europe is able to maintain a warmer
climate, in part,
thanks to these ocean currents.
So if those currents were to just somehow
stop, large parts of Europe
and North America would likely experience
incredibly long periods
of freezing conditions, devastating trade
and agriculture in those areas.
Now apply this to the world of One Piece.
The warmer waters inside
the Grand Line are essentially trapped
inside the Grand Line.
They can't be distributed to the northern
and southern parts of the world.
That would, in essence,
make those parts of the globe
permanent Arctic wastelands,
unfit for most habitation
let alone
any tropical island pirate adventures.
Now, all of this is awful.
And if One Piece were anything
remotely close to realistic,
this paints
a picture of a devastating hellscape.
Basically, half the world would be desert,
a lot of the northern
and southern hemispheres
would be frozen over,
and there would be very few resources
across the board
to sustain any sort of population.
The long and short of it,
the world of One Piece
is totally messed up.
Not only with the way the world is built,
result in something
completely unlivable
for a huge percentage of the surface,
but the natural phenomenon
that we see coming from the Grand Line
don't only make it dangerous for sailing,
it also completely destroys
any possibility
of technological advancement
on that planet.
Things would basically be stuck
at the technological level
of the Industrial Revolution or just
before, which hey, wouldn't you know it,
that's exactly
what we're seeing. In One Piece
everyone is basically just sailing ships
around.
Engines of any sort are exceedingly rare,
and any sort of transportation
or technology
usually comes from the use of the weird
wildlife on the planet or magical powers
granted by the Devil Fruit.
So in reality when you look at it,
for as scientifically inaccurate
as this world is the end result is largely
what you're seeing onscreen,
a bunch of people leaving their resource-
starved island in hunt
of something better.
Hi-diddle-dee-dee a pirate's life for me.
But hey, that's just a theory. A Film Theory!
And cut.